today we're talking about 10 PS5 games
with some of the most realistic Graphics
you'll find on any system that includes
PC and yes you can play every single one
of them right now the PS5 has been in
stores for nearly 3 years and we've
already seen quite a few games with
incredibly realistic Graphics consoles
have come a long way and are pumping out
games with lifelike details super clear
4K visuals effects like rage racing and
more number 10 Demon Souls one of the
launch titles for PS5 is still among the
best looking games on the system it's
all thanks to developer blueo games and
the remake of what was originally a PS3
game booting this up for the first time
was visually breathtaking and gave early
PS5 owners a standout title to showcase
the power of their new system comparing
this back to the original shows just how
far we've come in roughly a decade since
the PS3 version's release the
environments lighting Shadows volumetric
effects and realistic water are all on
full display here character models are
striking too I took so many screen shots
just in the little Hub area because I
was constantly in awe of these
environments there's a lot of enemies in
the game and while realistic may not be
the best description for these creatures
the level of detail here makes it easy
to imagine if the creatures actually
were real much of the armor and weaponry
looks as if it was ripped straight from
the Middle Ages the lighting and
particle effects are just as remarkable
there's also a lot here in the world
that reacts with realistic physics As
you move through it and this all comes
together in the combat with realistic
animations and blood spatter as you
attack and what has become a common
Trend this generation there are two
visual modes you can choose if you want
better visuals or better frame rate the
Cinematic mode is in 4k with a 30fps
Target where the performance mode runs
at a consistent 60fps while running at a
lower res and that's true for most of
the games on this list so I'm not going
to call that out every time but just
know you have the option with most of
these games to choose what you want to
prioritize with your experience number
nine The Last of Us Part One when The
Last of Us released on the PS3 it was
already a standout title when it comes
to visuals it struggled with performance
though which is which is probably why
Sony remade it for the PS4 what many
didn't expect though was for them to
remake it again on the PS5 and
regardless of how you feel about the
decision and whether or not this remake
was warranted there's no denying how
impressive things are here this version
has been fully remade for the PS5 now
Naughty Dog does pretty consistently
step up their game in the visual
Department they've been doing it for
years and that's all on full display
here with this version of The Last of Us
the character models and facial
animations are among the best in the
industry especially when it comes to
consoles the lighting skin tones even
the wrinkles on Joel's forehead they
bring these characters to life there's
also no denying the standout
performances by Troy Baker and Ashley
Johnson really helped to sell that
illusion of realism even more the
environment's just as impressive here
take this early game scene from Sarah's
bedroom and these interior shots inside
houses it's one of the things that
naughty dog just does so well maybe it's
because so many other games have us in
these Fantastical settings but there's
just something about the Simplicity of a
modern home and a bedroom that makes us
feel like we're right there with these
characters from the pictures and posters
on the wall wall to the overflowing
laundry got to say love the soccer
jersey you parents out there you know
all too well about having to quickly
wash the uniform for the next game then
when Sarah goes into the bedroom you
have this shot where she looks out the
window and sees the explosions it's a
very brief shot but the framing here of
us being inside this very real very
familiar home to then viewing these
explosions outside it really helps to
put you right there with Sarah to feel
that fear that she's experiencing in
that moment and considering most of the
game takes place in a post-apocalyptic
world you might think these moments
would end with the beginning of the game
as we progress though naughty dog again
puts us in these very familiar locations
like a house or a shop only now we see
the effects of the outbreak and so much
time passing number eight lies of PE
this game has blown me away in so many
ways since it's released back in
September it went from being a title I'd
never heard of to now being one of my
favorite games of the year it's amazing
to see such a quality game not only in
the visual department but across the
board released from such an unknown
developer I mean I mean these guys don't
even have their own Wikipedia page lies
of PE is based Loosely on the classic
story of Pinocchio and it's set in the
fictional world of crop definitely some
Bioshock Vibes and obviously the big
influence here is bloodborne the
environment the atmosphere the game
makes no effort to hide how much it's
been influenced by from software's
titles those environments they're
appropriately Grim here and the visuals
really help to sell that you're making
your way through what was once a virant
city the statues marble floors and
Gothic architecture they look fantastic
here running on Unreal Engine 4 we get
some nice weather effects and puddles
that reflect realistically excellent
physics on our main character with the
hair flowing in the wind and cloth
reacting to your movement there are also
some nice Elemental effects with fire
and lightning among others when it comes
to the weaponry and enemy designs the
attention to detail here really shows
the artistic talent of the team at Neo
wiiz seriously if you were on the fence
at all about this one it's absolutely
worth playing and not just for the
visuals number seven Hogwarts Legacy the
visual showcase here certainly surprised
many people in the industry by now more
and and more people are learning the
story of avalanche software a studio
that had focused mostly on making
licensed kid games before Hogwarts
Legacy the biggest thing that sticks out
here from the moment you reach Hogwarts
is the remarkable presentation of the
school itself it's a place many of us
are familiar with from the books and
while we saw it come to life in the
movies there's just something even more
special about being able to explore the
castle on your own in a 3D space the
attention to detail here is astounding
and everything from the architecture to
the lighting to the tiny little details
of the world they had to know only the
most hard fans would notice the game
takes place over the course of a full
school year so we get to see all four
seasons winter is my favorite season in
Hogwarts Legacy by far we get to see the
castle and the surrounding Highlands in
the snow and it feels like a scene right
out of the movies I've always loved snow
levels and snow effects in games I'm not
sure what it is exactly there's just
something so cozy about curling up under
a blanket while making your way through
a snowy area in a game it's not only the
outdoors though because the decorations
in and around Hogwarts changed with the
seasons as well in addition to Hogwarts
there's also an early game section
featuring gring gods and pretty early
you also get access to Hogs meat and
both of these locations are recreated
with that same level of polish that you
see with Hogwarts the character models
are pretty strong even if the map on the
facial animations felt a little off at
times then we have the spell and magic
effects which I guess we can't describe
as realistic but they definitely look
how I imagine magic would look you know
if it were actually real one of the very
first things I noticed is the subtle
trail of smoke that appears when you
cast spells it's such a little thing but
all those little things they really have
a way of adding up there are so many of
these moments where you can see how
Avalanche went the extra mile to polish
this game and honestly seeing them do
such a great job with Hogwarts has me
hopeful that we'll get a DLC or sequel
with even more locations like say the
ministry of magic number six Marvel
Spider-Man Miles Morales all right I
thought Spider-Man looked pretty good on
the PS4 but man oh man did Insomniac
really up their game with Miles Morales
on the PS5 it also seems like they're
doing the same thing with Spider-Man 2
which would have almost certainly been
on this list if you could you know play
it right now who knows maybe by the time
you're watching this you actually can
play it either way though even once that
game is out you can't go wrong with
Miles Morales like Demon Souls this
title released alongside the PS5 and was
yet another visual showcase for Sony's
new system all right you already know
how much I love snow in games and with
the events here taking place right
around Christmas we get to see not only
snow but holiday lights and decorations
as well as great as things look in the
Fidelity mode I just can't give up the
performance mode on this one the combat
and web slinging they're obviously two
of the standout features here and at
least for me Insomniac silky smooth
animation they look and feel so much
better on that performance mode now
remember how I said I thought the
original on PS4 looked and felt great
it's so funny how those things stick in
your mind and you remember it a certain
way but then when you actually go back
which is what I did I went back and
played that version I was thinking about
going for the platinum trophy may still
end up doing it but I was shocked at the
downgrade it was just way more of a
difference than what I was expecting
huge leap from Spider-Man on PS4 to
Spider-Man on PS5 now if Spider-Man 2 is
able to improve on the graphics of Miles
Morales in any way at all we're
certainly in for another visual ual
treat number five Gran Turismo 7 truth
be told I've never been a huge fan of
racing games that being said I cannot
deny how they've long been some of the
most visually impressive video games on
any system that's certainly true here
with Gran Turismo 7 one of the most
popular gaming franchises of all time
the seventh installment took the series
back to its roots complete with visuals
that show off what the PS5 can do of
course everything starts with the car
models and Gran Turismo knocks it out of
the park here the tires the headlamps
the fenders virtually every part you
would expect to see on a real world
version of the car is present here even
the Interiors show off Pan's commitment
to making the cars as realistic as
possible I mean think about this unless
you actually play using the cockpit view
where you really look carefully in
replays you're not even going to see
this but just notice the different
appearance of the materials in the car
here both on the steering wheel and on
the seats this is true for every single
car in the game while the cars are
certainly important what really takes
this game to the next level are the time
of day and weather effects the clouds
are Dynamic and they actually move to go
along with the weather weather and with
this the lighting constantly shifts and
changes based on the clouds in the sun
all the while light reflects
realistically on the car surfaces and
areas of the track when it rains you get
these missed particles and if you prefer
the game's cockpit view you'll even need
to use your windshield wipers to clear
away the rain as you drive Number Four
The Matrix awakens demo unfortunately on
this one you can only play it right now
if you already claimed it on your PS5
you see back in September of 2022 epic
released a playable Unreal Engine 5 Tech
demo featuring characters from The
Matrix this demo gave Gamers a firsthand
look at what Graphics may look like in
the very near future the near photo
realism of Kiana Reeves and keran Moss
was really impressive close-up shots
showed off eyebrows skin tones Shadows
wrinkles nearly every single detail on
these two actors then the demo shifts
into a car chase section the gameplay
here isn't anything out of the ordinary
and some would even say it felt a little
dated but that's not really the point of
the demo it was all about showcasing
what's possible in terms of visuals and
everything you see here just looks
incredible and of course it's important
that we remember all this is happening
in a very controlled contained space But
as you're going through this car chase
you've got sparks smoke glass breaking
frequent explosions it's all just a
visual Feast for the eyes and does a
great job doing exactly what epic set
out to do once you're finished with that
car chase scene you get a little more
freedom to explore and to really take in
all the finer details of which there are
plenty in both the city and the vehicles
even the NPCs look pretty good here now
if you ever downloaded this to your
system or even just claimed it on your
account you should still have access but
for whatever reason it was completely
removed a few mon after the initial
release number three ghost of sushima
director's cut now similar to Spider-Man
Miles Morales ghost of sushima
director's cut gives us a look at what
was originally a PS4 game now taking
full advantage of the power of the PS5
obviously there's a resolution boost
here to 4K as well as enhanced image
quality compared to PS4 one of the big
improvements came with the real-time
rendering of cutscenes that were
previously pre-rendered and this change
really helps to improve the lip syncing
with the Japanese dialogue this version
of the game offers a stable 60 frames
per second and on top of that load times
were significantly reduced as well now I
could go on and on about the technical
side of the improvements here but to be
totally honest with you the game looked
downright stunning on the PS4 and of
course it still looks stunning here on
the PS5 it's all thanks to the artists
and animators over at Sucker Punch the
cloth physics wind effects foliage
weather it really is the total package
here and I have to give huge props to
the depths here on what has actually
become a pet peeve of mine the total
absence of a UI at least when you're
exploring a game for me it always helps
me to get more immersed in the world let
me take in all the beauty of a game that
your team clearly worked so hard on
Crafting so many games these days
they're just cluttered with so much UI
now of course once you get into a battle
and need to use weapons or items a UI
will appear but it's all very minimal
and only shows exactly what you need and
because of the fact that it's Dynamic it
seamlessly Fades away the second you no
longer need it I honestly wish so many
games would just do this exact thing let
us see more of the world that you built
without the Clutter of that UI
especially in those moments when we
don't actually need it for any gameplay
function number two Horizon forbidden
West here we have yet another open world
game and truthfully I'm only now
realizing just how impressive it is that
so many of the games on this list a list
about incredibly realistic Graphics are
in fact open world when I was a kid
playing video games it was often the
case that the best looking games were
much more contained experience and while
that is still certainly true I mean we
just talked about cran Turismo 7 which
is a very specific type of game but the
fact that so many open world games are
looking this realistic Now is really
impressive even as recently as the first
few Uncharted games they were highly
Limited in how much you could explore
and that certainly has its advantages as
we've seen But even naughty dog has been
slowly adding more and more open areas
to their games but with forbidden West
you have this fully open world and
jaw-dropping Graphics all thanks to
gorilla's decimate engine many have
praised Horizon specifically for its
facial animations and skin tones not
only are these characters lifelike in
their appearance but also in how they
talk and move which has long been a
tricky thing for games to nail like
ghost of tsushima the foliage water
rendering Reflections and Light even the
ground textures are outstanding here you
also have volumetric effects like fog
and at times it's hard not to just stop
and take in the beautiful sky boxes that
are highlighted even more by the wide
range of biomes that you'll visit
gorilla even added underwater
exploration where things are equally
astounding then there are the machines
which showcase another big leap compared
to the first game on ps4 there are new
and improved animations for climbing and
swimming as well as a more robust
destruction system I've seen many fans
and commentators actually label
forbidden West as the best looking PS5
game ever in my mind it at least right
now there's really only one game that
tops it and of course it's all
subjective but for me number one God of
War Ragnarok I do have one bonus game
that I just have to mention next but in
my mind the top spot goes to what is not
only one of the best titles to show off
the PS5 is graphical capabilities but
also one of the best titles on the
system period for me I just have to
start with the character model of Kratos
I mean at this point he's one of the
most iconic characters in video games
and one of the closest things
PlayStation has to a mascot of course it
makes total sense that they would won
his PS5 debut to show him off in all his
full Godly glory and the model here is
better than it's ever been now I
couldn't find the official numbers in
terms of poly counts on Kratos for
Ragnarok but we know that in the PS4
version of God of War 2018 he had 80,000
polygons in total with 32,000 for the
face alone now it's one thing to hear
those numbers which let's be honest
unless you're an animator yourself it's
hard for us to really make sense of
those but when you see the cut scenes
here in game how the character moves and
talks and then you actually take control
of him in playable form it honestly
takes a moment to actually believe what
you're seeing especially if you're
someone around my age I mean I remember
seeing the cold breath of football
players on the PS2 version of Madden and
I thought Graphics can't possibly get
any better than this and then here now
today we have something that looks like
this of course all the technical bells
and whistles are great but it's really
the artart style here again this time
from the folks at Sony Santa Monica that
helped us set this one apart from
virtually everything else available on a
console right now the armor the weapons
the particle effects in addition to the
vast range of different environments
you'll find yourself in did I mention
there's snow lots of snow now we have to
be totally fair here when comparing this
to something like forbidden West because
admittedly it's not a truly open world
Ragnarok does a great job of giving you
the illusion of being open world and
that certainly plays a factor in how
much these games can do and how far they
can push the system I do have one bonus
title and it's one you may be surprised
not to see on this list it's Ratchet and
Clank Rift apart based purely on a
graphics perspective alone I don't know
that I have seen anything more
impressive more stunning than Ratchet
and Clank Rift apart of course the
reason it's not here on this list today
is that it's a much more stylized game
looking better than a Pixar movie at
times instead of going for something
like true to life realism that's right I
said it better than a Pixar movie at
times don't believe me check out the
video on the left side of your screen
now for my full breakdown big thanks to
all of our channel members for their
support and as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon